tengo una pregunta bien interesante que
se hicieron los ingenieros de khan
academy mientras estaban programando la
pregunta es la siguiente existirá algún
cuadrilátero a b c b aquí dibujé las
diagonales el punto de intersección
vamos a llamarle
bueno existirá un cuadrilátero en el
cual el ángulo a hebe sea igual al
ángulo acb acb osea poniéndolo aquí con
letras será posible que el ángulo a
ve sea congruente al ángulo a se ve
bueno aquí puedes pausar el vídeo para
pensar el problema si quieres ya voy a
empezar con la solución bueno para
pensar si existe o si no existe un
cuadrilátero así vamos a suponer que si
existe eso nos va a permitir trabajar
con algunas cosas vale entonces vamos a
suponer que sí que si podemos obtener
esta congruencia entonces supongamos que
ya dibujamos un cuadrilátero y cumple
que el ángulo ave es congruente al
ángulo acb al ángulo ángulo hace b va y
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es pensar
esta situación pero pues con osea sin
tanto ruido sin tener un cuadrilátero
nada más las puras rectas entonces
déjame pensar a abc en vez de como un
segmento como una recta o sea lo voy a
prolongar para acá y para acá y eso me
va a dar una cierta recta l que voy a
copiar de este lado va entonces por ahí
tenemos una recta l voy a hacer lo mismo
con b entonces ahora b
lo voy a pensar como un segmento de una
recta
que sigue para acá y para acá ya esta
recta le voy a llamar m
entonces la voy a copiar de este lado
más o menos como por aquí digamos va
entonces está de acá se llama m está acá
se llama él y finalmente voy a hacer lo
mismo con el segmento s entonces aquí lo
voy a prolongar esta prolongación se va
a llevar se va a llamar n y finalmente
la voy a copiar de este lado para que no
haya tanto tantos ruidos y tantas cosas
estorbando entonces aquí tenemos las
rectas l m y n y entonces que estamos
suponiendo cuando decimos que el ángulo
ave es congruente al ángulo acb bueno
pues el ángulo ave es el ángulo entre
las rectas n y ms este de aquí verdad
entonces déjame copiarlo para acá es
este vale es este ángulo y bueno al
suponer que es igual al acb estamos
suponiendo que es igual al de las rectas
o al ángulo entre las rectas l
y n entonces sería igual a este de acá
entonces aquí tenemos que estos dos
ángulos de aquí son congruentes bueno
pero esto nos va a llevar a problemas o
sea aquí ya más o menos se puede ver que
vamos a tener un problema este con la
con esta configuración de rectas a lo
mejor quiere pensar ahorita de qué se
trata ese problema puedes pasarle pero
bueno yo ahorita ya voy a empezar a
decir qué sucede lo que sucede es que
entonces tenemos que las rectas m y l
tienen una transversal una transversal n
y esa transversal n tiene ángulos
correspondientes congruentes entonces
qué sucede lo que tenemos a partir de
esta suposición que hicimos es que las
rectas m y l son paralelas entonces le
voy a poner aquí que la suposición nos
permite concluir que las rectas m y l
son paralelas pero eso es un problema
eso es un problema porque esto es
imposible verdad si las rectas m y l son
paralelas entonces pues cualquier
subconjunto de estas rectas va a ser
también paralelo entre sí es decir en
particular tenemos
tenemos que ver el segmento b
tiene que ser paralelo al segmento bc al
segmento bc pero qué sucede si el
segmento d y el segmento bc fueran
paralelos entonces no se podrían
interceptar en ningún lugar pero eso es
imposible verdad porque aquí en nuestra
figura el segmento b y el segmento bc se
intersectan justo en el punto b porque a
veces de era un cuadrilátero entonces
estoy aquí es imposible verdad esto de
aquí ya muestra un problema está con
nuestra suposición de que estos dos
ángulos sean iguales a partir debe de
suponer que éste es igual a éste vimos
que el segmento b y el bc no se pueden
interceptar pero eso es imposible porque
se intersectan en el punto b entonces
qué es lo que nos dice todo esto pues
justo nos dice que nuestra suposición de
que los ángulos este sean congruentes
está mal y por lo tanto es imposible
encontrar un cuadrilátero en el cual el
ángulo a hebe sea congruente al ángulo a
c b